with author tom wheeler on his new book
leadership lessons from the civil war
christmas weekend on c-span for more
schedule information go to our website
csband.org and click on guide to
programs
more from our 20th anniversary
historical series on the american
presidents next the first of four life
portraits will show you today we start
with president millard fillmore our 14th
chief executive last june we were live
at the fillmore house museum in east
aurora new york to examine his
presidency but first a brief
biographical look at his life and times
on the night of july 9 1850 vice
president millard fillmore received a
knock on the door of his willard hotel
room in washington dc
he was informed of the death of
president zachary taylor
the following morning at 11 am he
entered the house chamber and in front
of the gathered members of the house and
senate was quietly sworn in as the 13th
president of the united states
[Music]
millard fillmore was born on january 7
1800 in a log cabin on a farm in locke
township near moravian new york
the second of nine children he held odd
jobs and taught himself how to read with
a bible and a dictionary
at age 19 he entered school and became
the favorite student of 20 year old
abigail powers
the two eventually married in 1826
but not before fillmore became
established as a lawyer in east aurora
new york
a son millard powers was born in 1828 a
year before fillmore became a new york
assemblyman
daughter mary arrived in 1832 the same
year he was first elected to congress
fillmore was elected to three more terms
in the house and served as chairman of
the ways and means committee
the 5'10 fillmore was said to have been
well built dark-haired and handsome in
his youth
by the time he reached the presidency
however his hair had turned white and he
had gained considerable weight
although he was said to have been
amiable and well liked in small circles
his slow deliberate speeches were
interpreted as pragmatic and unemotional
by larger audiences
his wife abigail was frail by the time
her husband assumed the presidency and
their daughter mary often stood in for
her as the white house hostess
during her husband's tenure however
abigail a former school teacher was the
first to gain government appropriated
funds for a permanent white house
library
she died shortly after becoming ill
while attending the inauguration of
franklin pierce her husband's successor
the next year their daughter mary died
at the age of 22.
after his time in the white house
fillmore traveled extensively throughout
europe until 1856 when he was nominated
for the presidency by the american
native party also referred to as the
know-nothing party
he received only 22 percent of the
popular vote coming in third behind
james buchanan and john fremont
two years later he married a wealthy
widow caroline carmichael mcintosh
together they bought a mansion in
buffalo new york and fillmore became one
of the leading citizens of that city
until his death in 1874
during his time in office fillmore's
critics complained that he lacked the
ability to take a stand on issues
during the debate over the compromise of
1850 he was quoted as saying i detest
slavery but it is an existing evil for
which we are not responsible and we must
endure it and give it such protection as
is guaranteed by the constitution till
we can get rid of it
milestones during fillmore's term
included the laying of the cornerstone
for the current house chamber
plans for the layout of the mall and
south lawn of the white house
and the launching of the expedition to
japan by commodore matthew perry
throughout his life fillmore remained
modest when oxford university offered to
confer an honorary degree he declined
and stated i had not the advantage of a
classical education and no man should in
my judgment accept a degree he cannot
read
[Music]
he'll have a white house thunder in a
few days a few days he'll have the white
house going home
[Music]
no more
[Music]
he is going
[Music]
home in a few days
[Music]
these are fourth and fifth grade
students members of the egret road
elementary schools history club singing
a campaign song from 1856 when millard
fillmore our 13th president made a
second bid for the white house on a
third-party ticket called the no-nothing
party today we're visiting the town of
east aurora new york just outside
buffalo and the site of the only
remaining millard fillmore house where
he lived from 1826 to 1830 before the
white house today we'll spend two and a
half hours learning more about one of
our country's least known presidents
millard fillmore number 13 who served
from 1850 to 1853.
our guests are people who love history
and here's our lineup we'll be talking
with rachel francis who is a teacher and
author of a children's book called will
the real millard fillmore please stand
up also joining us on our set robert
scary who is a local historian and
author of a book on millard fillmore
and as the program continues you'll meet
more people who understand the period
and the time anthony cohen who is a
historian who learns history through
experiential research he walked thousand
miles of the underground railroad and
he'll be talking to us about the
politics of the time the compromise of
1850 and the fugitive slave act and
you'll meet marie schner who is
co-curator of the fillmore home here in
east aurora as always during our
american president series our phone
lines will be open we invite your
participation and our conversation the
phone numbers are
202-624-1111 for you in the eastern half
of the united states and
202-624-1115 for people in the mountain
and pacific times
here we are inside the living room of
millard fillmore's small home early in
his career i'm going to ask robert scary
to tell me you've
thought a lot about millard fillmore he
always is described as a forgotten
president someone we know so little
about why is he important to study
well i i feel that
i go along with maybe the people that
maybe we don't know too much about
i think he was much maligned uh in
history
i think sometimes unfairly
and when i came to moravia in
1959 i always was interested in the
president
and
i don't know i got more and more
interested in him
and i found a lot of things that i had
thought before
my mind was changed
rachel francis you're interested enough
that you've taught those young people we
just heard from to know who millard
fillmore is why
well i began guiding here about 18 years
ago as a docent in the fillmore house
and as i learned the story i thought
this is this is a story that that the
public needs to know
millard fillmore was a man who rose from
nothing born in a log cabin
and grew up with absolutely nothing but
he made something of himself mostly
because of a love of learning and i
thought that was a great story for uh
american children to learn
and learn more about this house but
since you served as a docent tell us a
little bit about its history
the history okay it was built it was
built in 1826 by millard himself we
think it's the only presidential home
built by the president
the president's own hands he built it
for his wife abigail
and
at that time it was up on main street
and it has been moved to this new
location in the 1930s
and it served as an artist gallery an
artist studio i should say
and in the 1970s it was finally
bought by the historical society and
returned back to millard fillmore's time
if you're one of those folks who will be
following in our footsteps to see more
of the presidential sites this is a
house that's available for tour and if
you fly into the buffalo airport it
takes you all of about half an hour at
max to get here to the town of east
aurora and eastward in addition to
claiming fame to millard fillmore is
also the foundation of the whole arts
and crafts movement in the early 1900s
of this country so there's a great deal
of local history in the area and today
we're going to focus on that period in
the middle 1800s some things to know
about millard fillmore he was the very
first president to be born in the 1800s
what are some other quick facts people
should know well we want to clear up
some misconceptions that the first
bathtub is a is a myth that's not his
first claim to fame but he did have the
first library in the white house thanks
to his very educated wife abigail who
thought it was scandalous that there was
no white house library when she arrived
there
as the 13th president
and in fact asked for congressional
appropriation that's correct began
building books now as a teacher you
might comment about millard fillmore's
apparent love of books
he grew up in a home where there were
three things to read an almanac
occasionally a newspaper from auburn and
the bible and so i think this
deprivation really
increased his hunger for learning
he also had very little schooling as he
grew up he would go for maybe three
months a year he was the firstborn son
of a poor farmer so he had to he had to
help his dad
so as he grew up he became more and more
interested in learning and he found
books as the key to that
and he joined one of the first libraries
in moravia in the finger lakes and was
one of the
most avid borrower books and
he and his wife shared this love of
learning and of reading and books and by
the time he was in his 30s he had
accumulated a library of about 4 000
books
we know many of you are historians uh
perhaps professionally perhaps amateur
historians who know a lot about the
presidents and we really welcome your
participation we'll keep those c-span
phone numbers on the screen and we'll go
to calls and mix in your comments if you
have questions we'll take them but if
you'd like to add to our body of
knowledge about the time period and also
about millard fillmore in particular we
do welcome that we have a map of this
area of new york state if you have not
been here before so you can see where we
are buffalo is the major city in the
area and you can see east aurora is
about 30 minutes about 18 miles
bird flies away from buffalo and moravia
the town we were just talking about from
fillmore's youth there on the map
farther in the central part of the state
and robert scary i'm going to ask you
since you know well about moravia talk
about what it was like at the very early
1800s what was the economy like how poor
were people people generally about his
roots
most most of them are farmers you gotta
remember that when he was born in 1800
um it was really wilderness in a sense
the brewery canal wasn't complete until
1825 and it wasn't begun until 1817
and so most of people were engaged in
farming
and and so on i mean uh it wasn't a
thriving
uh area and to have no formal education
would have been pretty common at the
time well they had the schools and uh
like in the case of fillmore uh he he
worked on a foreign farm in the summer
the only time he went to school was
really in the winter months
we have we've took taken some pictures
of his birthplace what exists of it
today today
well in 1981
where there was a split rail fence which
has since
been dismantled and so on
a flag pole and picnic tables
and that's it and we know that's the
site of uh the the cabin there's not lot
number seven
uh in the township of locke it's now
summer hill
and uh
of course the cabin uh
was destroyed along the way
and
in 1960
to
know 1963 to 65 we made a replica of his
cabin which is in fillmore glenn state
park and why are you hoping to have
people see what it was like in the time
what's the the goal of all of your
efforts
well i just feel that there was so much
negative things said about him
that and he's the president we've only
had what 42 we can count
41 with grover cleveland twice
i mean here's here's a person who from
humming humble surroundings that became
president united states
i wouldn't care if he was the worst
president
in our history he isn't but i'm just
saying if he was he's still president
united states and for people just to
make jokes and ignore him i think is bad
here on the screen is the replica of the
log cabin yes and that was done by
volunteers no help through the state
or federal government of which you were
one
yeah and uh we we put it there was a
cabin in the area
and we dismantled that
and then we
assembled it in two years and we'd have
worse sessions on weekends
i had students from my
high school american history class
working on it let's take our first call
about millard fillmore's from enid
oklahoma good morning
hi i have
a history professor in college
who used to have a lot of fun with
millard fillmore he called him the great
doe face
and on one occasion he told us that he
the professor was a member of the
millard fillmore society
and he said that they didn't have any
bylaws and they didn't elect any
officers and they didn't really do
anything but that's the way millard
fillmore would have wanted it
and i just wonder why he's gotten such a
bad rep from historians and i'll hang up
and listen thanks thank you rachel
francis i'd like to answer that uh
millard fillmore was sponsored at the
beginning of his political career by a
man named thurlow weed
and people who have studied 19th century
politics know that thurlow weed was a
background backroom
president maker he was the politician
who arranged who was going to run for
office and when and so forth at the
beginning of fillmore's career thurlow
weed was as i said his sponsor and put
him forth as a wonderful candidate and
as time went by thurlow weed switched
over to william seward from auburn who
was on his path to being an abolitionist
and millard got abandoned by thurlow
weed thurlow weed eventually became
pretty much his enemy and because weed
was also a newspaper editor he had the
power of the press to say and write
whatever he wished about the people he
didn't like
it was thurlow weed who wrote millard
fillmore's first
biography sort of as a piece of his own
autobiography and he slammed millard
fillmore very badly and i just
i i think what a horrible fate to have
your biography written by your worst
enemy and this is what happened to
millard fillmore and he got a bad rap
right off the bat
as far as the doe face thing that was
the term that was given to
the presidents who had they were from
the north but they had southern leanings
and i don't think millard really
qualifies with that because he was a
president who was dedicated to
uh maintaining the union he wanted to
keep the country together he wanted to
be a president of the whole country
and because of that he was involved with
a compromise of 1850 which is the
the strongest hallmark of his presidency
so i that's why he got such a bad rap i
blame thurlow weed
well thurlow weed's work continues to
this day there are a number of things
such as the millard fillmore society
that poke fun at our 13th president one
of the things we found is this book for
children which i'm sure you've seen
before this was given to us by joshua
pete now if you've been watching this
series from the very beginning you'll
remember joshua's the young man who
joined us at our very first program from
the national portrait gallery who at the
tender age of about seven can name all
the presidents forward and backward he
brought this book along but as you can
see the title of it is yo millard
fillmore and all those other presidents
you don't know well we hope by the end
of this program we'll know more about
millard fillmore and let's take our next
telephone call which is from rochester
new york
yes my name is alison gamby and my
grandfather and my uncle were both named
from millard filmore
and also my father it was also in danger
of the yard and our our home was from
uh used to be around the moravia auburn
that area
and did your uh your uh
folks in your family know about millard
fillmore since they had his name yeah
yeah they were very much
history magnetic family they very much
my father was my father's birthday which
is november 4th was always tickled to
death and voting on his birthday because
he was
voting on his birthday was very much a
serious
matter to him so he very much
enjoyed voting on his birthday when
november 4th happens beyond merchandise
thank you november 4th is millard
fillmore's birthday is that right
january 7th january 7th
1800 i'd like to add to some of the
things that the comments that were made
uh that society along with some others
they do poke phone at fillmore and they
get a lot of attention
i mean this thing said about filmore
that
he was nothing that's what harry truman
said that's why zachary taylor picked
filmore he was in nothing
he did nothing before the civil war and
all that i mean i got upset with that he
had no charisma
all you hear are all these negative
things i'll give you some examples when
he's a member of congress
okay if he had no charisma so on he went
into congress 1832
in eight years in 1840 he's up for
speaker of the house
he was defeated finished second to fall
in tennessee
he became chairman of the house ways and
means committee for two years he was the
father of the tariff which should have
borrowed his name tariff of 1842 and
then in 1842 can you imagine this
fillmore had had some uh
with a
telegraph of morse
and so we asked congress for an
appropriation of thirty thousand dollars
to help this inventor he got it can you
imagine
i had this inventor i know and you try
to get an appropriation of money he he
got that he left the congress because he
missed his family and that
now to be considered for speaker the
house
must have something you know
and you go on and on the presidency
okay he sent troops into north and south
carolina
after was a meeting in nashville in
november of 1850 there was threat of
secession the only state
that really had that going was south
carolina
south carolina at the time when he sent
troops into that state
plus strengthening charleston the fort
the fourth third charleston
the legislature of south carolina passed
legislation protesting that
the governor whose name was seabrook
he writes and wants to know why filmware
did that
the answer he felt because it was a
governor who asked this
was given by his secretary of state
daniel webster
he's commander-in-chief
he sent troops into new mexico when
texas
threatened to annex it
and it was the same thing that taylor
had done when he was president he
threatened to send troops and took
fillmore did but it was settled because
texas got 10 million dollars for the
boundary uh question
now you know that shows action
johnsville st johnsville new york is
next as we talk about millard fillmore
good morning yeah good morning um i'm
not calling the malign millard fillmore
again but i remember hearing a few years
back that uh there was some suspicion
about millard fillmore when zachary
taylor died in office
and uh i'd just like to hear your
comment i'll hang up now suspicion of
what sir
oh do you know the answer sure this was
brought up in last week's program the uh
the disinterment of zachary taylor to
see if there was arsenic and when i
heard about this in the national media i
was highly amused because millard
fillmore as a as a candidate for this
evil deed was
just completely uncharacteristic he was
a very
gracious polite
kind man
everyone spoke highly of him except
people who had newspapers of the
opposite political persuasion were the
rumors even at the time that he might
have been oh not at all so this occurred
later on in history this was this was uh
in the 90s it was the woman who was on
your show last week who was writing a
book about zachary taylor and um
had suspicions that maybe he didn't just
die of cholera morbidis
that maybe someone had been involved in
an evil plot but i think it was proven
untrue millard was exonerated along with
that exactly zachary taylor uh of course
wasn't and bound
if he had been arsenic was used in
bounding back in those days so
if arsenic had been discovered uh
what would you have said right and test
proved that it was not the case as we
learned last week
south san francisco california good
morning
hello you're on the air welcome
i'd like to thank c-span for presenting
the series it's been fascinating to
watch i've got glad you're watching
i've got two questions from mr scary
uh first uh
hearing about all these clubs uh doc and
fillmore there seems to be a serious
reappraisal of his performance by
historians
he's been traditionally portrayed as a
weak or mediocre individual a politician
of limited ability that several work
recent works
seem to go against this view however
a book on vice presidents have put out a
chapter on fillmore written by dietrich
ulrich states
prolific critics and political enemies
of fillmore's generation labeled him as
an ineffective self-serving politician
who lacked insight in political finesse
modern historians on the other hand
characterized fillmore as an energetic
and modest individual whose perseverance
and self-sacrifice lifted him into the
forefront of antebellum politics
i could cite similar works from
publications including burke's
presidential families
but would ask
mr scary if he agrees this positive
reappraisal of fillmore seems to be
taking place and second
also to mr scary
it was uh generally accepted directions
and fillmore's son's will to carry uh
were carried out to destroy all family
correspondence um
a discovery of over 10 000 pieces of
fillmore's correspondence in 1967
indicates fillmore's uh son's wishes
were not carried out
and mr scary are you aware of any
full-length biography on fillmore now in
existence or to be published which
incorporates information from this mind
all right let's thanks for all those
questions we'll dissect them the first
uh question really is is there in
addition to both of you who are working
on this but is there generally among a
larger group of historians a more
positive reassessment of fillmore's
history going on right now well i i
don't know i know uh in unpublished
manuscript i have until more dealt with
the papers in oswego
and to me i felt that i accomplished
some things that
are not in earlier biographies because
if you were a writer then you relied on
the papers that were in buffalo
and uh so you know about the son's
papers that he wrote oh yes i could
never understand that why his son
he said that uh
he
that the paper should be destroyed
well the executor of the state didn't
follow the son's wishes now maybe the
sun destroyed some before he died
but i just could never understand it
because if you go through his papers
um i don't see anything
so bad
that you'd have to destroy him or
something like that
uh rachel franklin you never explained
why he
could you tell us about his family we
referenced his wife but talk about a
little bit about who she was and about
the children please he had two children
his firstborn was born in this house in
1828 millard powers film or the one we
were referring to he was
a very very shy young man and
they wrote that when he was a young man
he could not enter a room in which he
didn't he didn't know everyone he had to
know everyone in the room before he
could enter
he grew up to be his
father's secretary in the white house he
studied law he went to harvard
but he never practiced um
trial by jury he would never be able to
to be so brave uh his his
loss of his mother and eventually his
sister was devastating to him
and uh his
uh
death notice said that he was just his
the soul was ripped out of him when he
lost both of them it was also difficult
for him to hear the criticism of his
father
and so i i perceive him as a very
unhappy
man all through his life
uh he was not happy with millard's
second wife
and when miller died he asked for the
two of them to do their best to get
along and it didn't happen
um
unhappy man never married the daughter
was like the complete opposite mary
abigail was born in 32 in buffalo and
she was everything anybody would ever
want a daughter to be she was
talented vivacious
very bright she could speak four
languages she played the harp and the
piano she painted botanical prints we
have examples of all these in the
library
and
a very engaging and personable young
lady as your opening piece showed he she
served as the hostess in the white house
often because her mother
had
what they said was a permanently broken
ankle and so it was very difficult for
her to stand in receiving lines for very
long so this young daughter
um
20 years old at the time
stood in for her in her mother in the
white house and people spoke of how
well-bred she appeared to be how
comfortable she was with anybody who
visited from around the world
she was just wonderful and it was a
heart heartbreaking loss for millard and
his son millard powers to lose her at
the age of 22. she died of color yes
here in east aurora
she had come out from her parents her
father's home
after her mother died
abigail the daughter took over the
running of the household in buffalo and
millard wrote with great appreciation
about how capably she did that she was
just a wonderful villain
and
one day
in july of 1854
she asked if she could go out to east
aurora and visit her grandparents
millard's
father and stepmother
and so she did she had her two o'clock
german lesson and then she took the
stage
out here to east devorah and had a
lovely evening with her
grandparents helped them move into the
new house that her father had bought for
her grandparents
and went to bed around nine o'clock
and after that she started to feel ill
and because she didn't want to disturb
her grandparents she did not let them
know
and finally they realized that she was
dare terribly sick they sent for the
doctor they sent for millard and powers
who came quickly out from buffalo and by
the time they came out here she was not
even able to speak she was unconscious
and she died the middle of the next day
it was a heartbreaking loss
age 22 and the fillmore family are
buried in the forest lawn cemetery in
buffalo new york and
there's quite a grave marker there you
can go visit if you are making a
presidential history tour let's take a
call next talmadge ohio good morning oh
yes i'd like to thank you for doing this
series on the american presidents it's
wonderful
first i have a question and then a
comment
my comment is daniel webster served as
millard fillmore's secretary of state
when serving under fillmore he became
the first man to serve as this post
twice
he had previously served under harrison
and then of course into the tyler
administration when harrison died
my question is i'd like you for you to
talk about
phoebe millard fillmore gilmore's mother
for which he was named for thank you
thank you
daniel webster twice secretary of state
yes that's correct and uh second
question was on was it on phoebe
well
her last name was millard
her father's a doctor in pittsfield
massachusetts
and that's where you get the the millard
so his first name came from his mother's
last mother's side
i'd like that by the way answer the
question that that gentleman in uh
california would call and asked about
the vice presidency
and sometimes the comments about his
an interesting inaudible you know you
had seward
who be
fillmore was controller of the state of
new york in 1848 when taylor won
and fillmore didn't go to washington
right away
he wanted to complete his duties
meanwhile seward uh went to the city and
went on to baltimore where he had a
litigation a settlement
and uh
the idea was he got to meet
members of the taylor family
and so right away by the time tillemar
reaches washington and the shenanigans
of
both weed and
seward
they begin to undermine
fillmore this way at that time you had
the spoil system
and that was in effect until you had
civil service
and the trouble was fillmore as vice
president people are seeking jobs and he
just couldn't seem to get jobs for them
whereas weed and seward
were able to do so
and he uh
made some
enemies there now fillmore wasn't stupid
he had friends who would write him
on what was going on including uh two
law partners nathan k hall and solomon g
i mean uh solomon g haven
okay
and uh in fact there's a civil war
historian called seward the iago
of the whig party
there's a lot more you could say about
the whole thing
we are going to introduce you in a
minute to one of the women who works
here as co-curator but before we do let
me tell you about our two guests here on
our set robert scary is as we've talked
about a local historian but before that
he served in the marine corps during
world war ii then moved on to teach high
school for 23 years at moravia high
school here in this part of new york
born and raised in waterford new york
and his education is from northern
illinois university bs in physical
education and ms and secondary education
he has written from his research a
thousand page manuscript that is a
biography of miller fillmore still
looking for a publisher you i've got a
publisher industry
and
what's what's the prognosis
well very good
what are your expectations if i get it
edited by i'd say maybe the end of
august a good chance of it maybe in the
year 2000. we'll be looking i'm very
happy about it i bet after all that work
rachel francis is also from this area of
new york state her education is at the
king's college
and also the university of buffalo
masters degree in elementary education
born and raised in southern new jersey
but has lived for a long time in this
part of new york state in addition to
her history work she is a third grade
teacher at the edgard elementary school
in orchard park and lives here in the
town of east aurora and tell me about
your children's book well the real
millard fillmore please stand up i'm a
great admirer of gene fritz biographies
for children and i've tried to model it
after her style with a lot of humanity a
lot of
stories anecdotes
mind is more the the more the life and
times uh of course if you're going to
write for children you you don't go
heavy on the politics but
millard's life was so important in the
in the telling of the 19th century he
was so involved in all the key issues
and the slavery issues and
things like that so it's about 20
chapters long i'm still looking for a
publisher i've been
so busy with teaching that i have put it
on the back burner for sure but i'd love
to see it published someday
let's introduce you to marie schneider
who is joining us in the library of the
millard fillmore house here in east
aurora new york and we'll learn a little
bit more about this particular building
and the role it played in millard
fillmore's library good morning and
thank you for allowing us to bring our
cameras inside where are you standing
right now i'm standing and leaning on
the rosewood piano which belonged to the
fillmores and was used in the white
house abigail played it mary abigail
played it
it's a very beautiful piano and we're
very happy to have it
this room was added by
mrs
price when the house was moved here in
1930
and we're glad she added it because it's
a place to keep all this furniture which
is connected very closely with
abigail and millard filmore and his
later life
i would like to tell you about one of
the most important
things that we have in the library and
that is our bookcase
the mahogany bookcase
which housed the first white house
permanent library
it was abigail who was the first
librarian in the white house and she was
responsible for there being a permanent
library in the white house
she when she moved into the white house
she was very upset there wasn't even a
dictionary or a bible and she was a
daughter of a minister no bible
and there were no other books because
what a president would do would bring
his own books and then take him with him
when he left no permanent library and
she thought there should be a permanent
presidential library so through her
husband she got a small amount of money
from congress and she bought some books
including of course a lot a dictionary
and a bible
and some books that were popular at the
time such as factories vanity fair
boswell's life of johnson
hawthorne's scarlet letter
and
using this mahogany bookcase which you
see here
she had it moved into one of the rooms
in the white house that wasn't used and
that's the start of the permanent
library in the white house then she also
had our beautiful rosewood piano moved
up there and the harp
and she used that room as a place where
she would entertain friends she'd serve
tea she might play the piano mary
abigail might play the harp and sing and
that was how she entertained uh her
friends her close friends marie
schneider may i ask you about the
millard film or portrait that's right
over your shoulder yes
that is one of the last portraits that
was probably done of millard it was
painted by a man by the name of augustus
rockwell and it shows millard fillmore
was a very dignified looking man i think
he looks like a statesman uh he with his
uh silvery white hair and his broad
shoulders and he was tall for that
generation he was almost six foot tall
and the story is that when he went to
london and was interviewed by and was
presented to queen victoria she is
supposed to have said he's the
handsomest man or maybe the most courtly
man that she had ever seen
another
artifact in the room that if you would
spend a minute on is over the fireplace
and it is perhaps engraving but it's of
henry clay right
and it's interesting because that was
taken at the time that millard filmo was
vice president and seated up in the
right-hand side you can see millard
presiding over the senate and that was
when henry clay was
talking to the senate they were debating
the compromise of 1850 and at that time
of course zachary taylor was still
president and the bill was finally
passed after millard fillmore became
president and he did sign the compromise
of 1850 which was a very important uh
document for that time barbra story what
was his relationship with clay
um
he wasn't particularly uh friendly with
clay as i remember uh the story there
were times when uh at one point he was
and at another point he disagreed with
him and of course at one time i guess
clay was going to run for president and
millard wasn't too happy about that
marie schneider stay there for just a
second i'll come back to you in a minute
i want to hear also robert scary's
thoughts on the relationship between
henry clay and millard fillmore well in
1844 i mean
clay ran for the presidency and fillmore
is running for governor in new york
state they both lost
but
they seemed to
get along all right
and filmore would go to kentucky even
after cl uh clay had died
uh and he would visit ashland his home
his gr his tomb
and so on
well you know in politics you might
occasionally disagree or agree on some
subjects but i think by and large did
clay thought highly of somewhere he he
recommended that in 1852 that the whig
party renominated him for presidency
clay of course the man who was burning
with ambition to be president of the
united states himself and he watches
miller feel more get there
on that on the debates i i think this is
something that should be brought out
for three decades nothing had happened
on a slavery issue
and there was really gridlock in a way
in in congress
uh fillmore as vice president sat in and
listened to the debates
of calhoun
and clay and webster
an incident happened one time when uh uh
the senator from mississippi his name is
foot
he was a violent person he's fought
several duels he pulled a pistol
on uh
tom's heart benton
for because benton had made some remarks
about calhoun
and they rested the pistol from his hand
and locked it in the desk but this is
the kind of things were going on i think
this is part of the reason why when
fillmore became president
he did
sign measures which that by the way came
one by one
they caught the ominous omnibus bill
under clay when there was one whole bill
you had a vote for it or not and i think
the idea was that taylor probably would
have vetoed it well it's the compromise
of 1850 that we're talking about with
five separate pieces of legislation
let's return to marie schneider for just
a little bit of explanation about how
this house is funded
how's it all come together how has it
all come together well we do charge an
admission charge of course uh we have
quite a few people who come during the
summer to visit the house we're open
from june until october and um it's
funded for through the easter historical
society any other
funds that we need there are
fundraising
things during the year that help fund it
no federal or state money no federal or
state money we are thinking of applying
for uh some sort of grant and
that is being worked on how much does it
cost to visit and and mostly it's funded
as i say through the we sell things we
have artifacts that we sell we do charge
admission and that's the way we keep it
going what's the admission price
how much does it cost to visit i can't
hear her she's lost do you know how much
the charge is now i think it's two
dollars
the
cost to visit is two dollars per person
it's not expensive at all and then we do
have a lot of special tours that come
and uh and then also we have people who
will call and ask to us do a special
tour and often uh now one gentleman gave
me a check for a hundred dollars because
i did uh just a special tour for himself
and his wife and he came from louisiana
and he appreciated that it was a day
that we weren't open and an unusual time
of the day and so every once in a while
we do get some special
funds from someone who is much
interested in our house we hope that
we'll bring you a few more visitors can
you hear me now yes i can
last question for you because we will be
visiting with you again is your own
interest why are you interested in
millard fillmore why am i interested in
miller film well i've always been
interested in history although i was a
second grade teacher i always loved to
read about history and when i moved to
east aurora around
40 some years ago and i discovered it
was the home of millard film i became
very much interested in him and as i
travel i have people who asked me about
east aurora and about millard fillmore
and that has kept my interest up because
i want other people to know about our
town and our home and about millard
fillmore well thank you we will learn
more about this house later on in the
program and thank you for allowing us to
come visit let's return to telephone
calls columbus ohio next good morning
good morning ma'am
samuel f b morris was very anti-catholic
as was the know-nothing party
was millard fillmore himself
anti-catholic i'll hang up on this for
your answer
thank you thank you
um
he i don't believe he was at all
anti-catholic he had uh close
relationships with people of the
catholic faith uh
the know-nothing party i think was a
vehicle for him
he i think he believed that he may have
been the only person to keep be able to
keep the country together in such a
perilous time in 56
and it was only after a lot of
persuasion from people and supporters
that he agreed to run for president
under the no-nothing party
he never ever
put forth
the beliefs that the know-nothing party
had i'm sure he shared some concerns for
the enormous immigration that was coming
in at that time
and he was concerned about manipulation
by unscrupulous politicians of the
immigrants and so there was some
concern for the immigration and that was
the basis of the
american party but uh the anti-catholic
thing i don't think was a personal
conviction of his at all and and it's
it's interesting to look back now from
this perspective
it may have been true that he was the
only person who could keep the country
together at that time and as we know uh
when a republican was elected in in 1860
that did cause the immediate cessation
of
of the union and that republican was
abraham abraham lincoln the know-nothing
party was formally known as the american
party no nothing was a nickname what did
it come from
how did they get the name know nothings
well uh someone asked it was this sort
of a secret society somebody said you
know what he'd stand for and a person
replied i know nothing
but
take
fillmore and catholicism the only only
thing i ever found in any of his papers
where by he would write
sort of a
upset with
catholics would be in 1844 when he and
clay clay was running for the presidency
and
fillmore as governor
and he felt that
there was an anti-vote against him and
he sort of singled out in one and one
group the
catholics but on the other hand
during this time in 1856 when this
movement was on
a bishop in buffalo was very easy on
fillmore for a simple reason that
fillmore and three churches contributed
bells
uh to the to the churches he also you
find his writings he's very pro-irish
uh in support of money and did i read
that he had an audience with the pope
during his european union yes he did uh
pope pius ix
now when going back to that visit too
that comment by queen victoria now
that's in fact every book you find out
my life what i tried to do in my writing
was i wanted to find out how true some
of these statements were
and from the british
you know you have sort of like a royal
secretary
and they take if you have an uh
dinner with let's say the queen or some
kind of affair there's somebody
recording everything
and there's nothing recorded in writing
about queen victoria saying this and of
course the answer was
she might have said it okay
and i think this comment came from years
after fillmore died maybe about 10 years
some people in buffalo reminisced
about his life and a lot of comments
came forth
like he refused a degree
in oxford because he couldn't read latin
and i
wrote oxford
no no record of it and so on so there
are a number of myths about millard
fillmore oh yes and the same thing on
the on the bathtub h.l menken wrote a
essay in 1917
and it's world war one is very serious
time and so does a satire and he's it
was a hoax
it got accepted and in 1926 he wrote
another essay saying it was a hoax he
said you compare it with washington
cutting down the cherry tree
but they're so accepted he could you
couldn't do anything about it it was
just part of the
thing we'll learn more about the bathtub
story we're going to talk to some
students here who are in an annual
bathtub race in this part of the country
just to support millard fillmore's
history
the know-nothing party let's just
complete that thought 1856 and millard
fillmore was their candidate but he came
in third place the winner that year was
mr buchanan of pennsylvania we're
talking about president millard fillmore
who served from 1850 to 1853 never
elected in his own right came into
office after the death of zachary taylor
and next call about him is from everett
washington good morning
good morning excellent program
i was calling
uh mrs francis is charming
and uh
she looks so sweet looks like i'm a
grandmother anyway
mr scary seems to
be really aggravated or upset because uh
the president fillmore is not getting
his due
and uh i sort of agree with him because
anybody that can come from a log cabin
and become president united states even
if he didn't accomplish
what people i don't know what they say
but uh
i do agree with him that
that's quite an accomplishment and uh
i'll hang up and just listen i do enjoy
your program you're very it's a good
program thank you very much
mr scary are you angry about that
fillmore's history no i in fact
i agree with the with the caller there
and some of his comments there uh no i'm
not
well you say aggravated sometimes uh
it's the negative things that you hear
so much it's just like on a person
you know this is all you heard and
nothing positive you know
um i'm not i'm not trying to say that
fillmore didn't make mistakes and so on
and so forth we all do but uh
the whole point is that uh
you just seem to hear the negative
things that's why i got interested in
i'm always been for say the underdog in
a way you know even the sports
we've referenced the fugitive slave act
and the compromise of 1850 in about 25
minutes you will meet anthony cohen
whose expertise is on the history of the
period especially about the slavery
issue issue and the abolitionist
movement very very prevalent in this
part of the country and we'll be
learning more about that which was
really a framework of much of the
politics of millard fillmore's history
that's about 25 minutes from now san
diego is next good morning yes i'm a
black caller and i must tell you that i
am somewhat upset matter of fact i am
very upset because um we as black
americans must endure time after time a
large segment of america putting forth
men like phil moore attempting to
rehabilitate him and i tell you every
time that we have to endure this it
really it really sets back race
relations and it really does a lot to
tear at the hearts of black americans
and i must say that fillmore made a lot
more than mistakes
this is a man who's guilty of crimes
against his humanity
i think that in a sense as a black
america i can tell you he was a rather
sick man
and i'll tell you why i mean here is a
man
who actually backed the future to slave
law
he was involved in this uh you know
for for years
and uh
black america we're not going to forgive
this man and i was wondering now
why is it that oh how is it that c-span
and the gentleman and the lady sitting
over there can sit here with straight
faces and talk about this man
who really should not have any monuments
could you like i
i'm just really upset about this could
he answer that and i'd like to say one
final thing when he answers
okay now
uh i i can see her point
but you know when these bill when these
measures were signed the last
thing that gilmore hesitated to simon
the fugitive slave act
he asked his attorney general whether it
was constitutional
fillmore
said as president
that the constitution was my guide
slavery was an evil
but it was part of our system
and so on
and uh the caller might be surprised
that when
lincoln was inaugurated
he said that he would
not interfere with slavery where it
already existed but he was opposed to
its extension into the territories
and he supported the fugitive slave act
now uh the trouble with i think a lot of
this was that if you go back to 1793
with washington there was a similar law
but it was never enforced
and i think fillmore as a
constitutionalist
when the fugitive slave act was passed
what he did was he he wouldn't use
military action to enforce it he'd use
marshals
and as a consequence in boston
philadelphia syracuse
there were slaves that were incarcerated
in the jail somewhat unfairly in fact
particularly the one in syracuse called
the jerry if there
and mob stormed the jail and freed the
individual and then they were
transported to canada
but phil
fillmore knew too that when he signed
the fugitive slave act
that this is probably his political
career i think he showed a lot of
courage and i would say this if civil
war had started
in 1850 instead of 1861
i think
the north would have lost they barely
won
when they when it was fought between
1861-65
so you know you're talking
1999 with 1850 and a period there's a
lot of and even today sometimes there's
a lot of emotionalism in what's going on
around us instead of fact
rachel francis your job is to teach the
history of this period to very young
people third graders can you talk a
little bit about how you deal with it
well it's interesting i agree with the
caller to a great extent
my young yorkers and i have just
completed a year-long project of
researching the underground railroad and
we just put out a book called secrets
along the niagara
based on the research in this area on
the underground railroad this was a very
active
area of the country as you can imagine
because of our border connection to
canada here
and
i think fillmore signed this because he
had spent that time in congress
uh ruling over uh the procedures of
congress listening to all
the arguments he knew exactly how
volatile the issue was he personally was
as we said abhorrent to slavery and
never ever was involved personally in a
with a slave
as in that relationship
but he understood that uh
this was something he had to tolerate it
was the only thing the south won out of
the compromise of 1850 everything else
was pro north
and he realized like as mr skari said
that this would be his political death
his wife told him if you sign this it
will be your political death he was
willing to do that to keep the country
together it wasn't a personal um
conviction of his at all he thought
his obligation was to preserve the union
oh you're still there
all right we'll move on then to
woodridge new york good morning good
morning i had
recently read a biography of dorothea
dix
and in it i was surprised to learn of
her friendship with president fillmore
she was friendly with him when he was
vice president and after his wife's
death
the book seems to indicate a
romantic
involvement through letters and then a
disappointment when
it didn't go any further than that and i
just wondered if you could comment
further about this friendship and
relationship between dorothea dix and
president fillmore
caller don't hang up are you still there
oh okay explain who dorothea dix is
please
dorothea dix was a social reformer of
that time particularly
interested in the conditions of the
insane
and she was also very much concerned
about nursing conditions at that time
thank you very much
robert scary can you enlighten us
anymore well uh
gilmore uh she she would visit fillmore
at the white house and they corresponded
he was very she he was very much for her
endeavor again on the insane
uh but he couldn't get congress to uh
you know pass anything that was that was
the problem
but they did corresponded and just i
think it was just a
friendly relationship nothing else
people make a lot of do about
about things like this same thing with
some letters with anna carroll
during his time
we're going to return rachel francis to
the whole thought of millard fillmore
and the bathtub in the white house
you've brought along if you can very
briefly uh show us the hl menkin column
that got this all started
all right as mr scary said h l menken
wrote this in december 1917
and he wrote later that he was doing
this just to throw people off of their
um involvement with world war one he
wrote an essay entitled a neglected
anniversary celebrating the 75th
anniversary of the introduction of the
bathtub to the united states he fills it
with fascinating details including this
but it was the example of president
millard fillmore that even more than
grudging medical approval gave the
bathtub recognition and respectability
in the united states
while he was still vice president in
march 1850 he visited
intervention and on succeeding to the
presidency at taylor's death july 9 1850
see mention works in all these true
details
he instructed his secretary of war
general charles m conrad to invite
tenders for the construction of a
bathtub in the white house
the elder bennett in the new york herald
charged that fillmore aspired to buy and
install in the white house a porphyry
and alabaster bath that had been used by
louis philippe at versailles completely
unlike millard fillmore he was a very
simple but elegant man
then mankind remained silent for almost
nine years before he wrote a column
named ironically him to the truth he
refers to the above article that he'd
written
the article thrown off as a relief from
the patriotic libido of wartime was in
substance a burlesque history of the
bathtub i may confess that when it was
done i fancied it no little it was
artfully devised and it contained some
buffooneries of considerable juiciness i
had confidence that the customers of the
evening maine would like it alas they
liked it only too well
that is to say they swallowed it as
gospel bravely and horribly worse they
began sending clippings of it to friends
east west north and south and so it
spread to other papers and then to the
magazines and weeklies of opinion and
then to the scientific press and finally
to the reference books and you will find
it in encyclopedias
to this day it is in circulation and as
i say has broken into the reference
books and is their embalmed for the
instruction and edification of
prosperity
it was menken's little joke on the
gullibility of american readers and he
paid no price for his little lie
only millard has
millard fillmore did not bring the first
bathtub to the white house but next
you're going to meet by telephone amanda
lockett who is a student at millard
fillmore elementary school in moravian
new york who's going to tell us about
how moravia celebrates fillmore days
good morning amanda lockett hi
what are what are fillmore days
filmer days is an event that we
celebrate
millard fillmore's
presidency and when did they happen
we they have on the last friday and
saturday of june
and what happens during fillmore days
well
the highlights of fillmore days is a
bathtub race down the main street of
town we do this because some people say
that mueller filmer was the first
president to have indoor plumbing
people come from all over to race the
tubs down the street some teams win
prizes for the best decorated tub the
fastest tub and the tub that comes the
longest distance
have you ever raced a bathtub i have not
would you like to
i don't think i would because
they swerve a lot and sometimes go into
the crowds yeah i think bathtubs would
be hard to maneuver on a street yeah
what is it like watching it
watching it it's really fun it's
you watch the tubs
and
they
when they go into the crowds they really
make a commotion has anyone ever gotten
run over by a bathtub no that's good
don't want to make this dangerous now
you go to millard fillmore elementary
school and your town has fillmore days
what do you know about millard fillmore
you know anything in particular that you
think is interesting you don't know
anything about them
well would you like to know something
about it how about posing a question for
our guests okay
my question
has to do with millard fillmore's wife
abigail powers i know she married milo
millard
here in moravia in that she was a
schoolteacher but can you tell me
anything else about her
all right why don't you stay on the
telephone and we'll get an answer to see
if you have a follow-up question
abigail was the daughter of a baptist
minister
she had moved to moravia with her mother
after the minister had died the mother
thought that her money could go farther
in the frontier which is what moravia
was then and abigail grew up as the
one of two daughters five older brothers
and she was very intellectual she taught
school in the moravia area and at the
age of 21 she met 19 year old millard
and that's another misconception we
would like to correct we a lot of books
say that she was his teacher
as in the effect of standing in front of
a classroom with miller dis one of the
students i don't think that was the case
i think they studied together and they
became co-learners they
were passionate about their study of
geography and history and shakespeare
and so forth
and
millard realized that he needed to make
something of himself to deserve this
wonderful abigail because she was of a
higher social level than he
so he went off on a quest then to make
something of himself became a lawyer
came over to east aurora in buffalo to
accomplish that and then at the age of
26 he finally married his abigail who
was at that time
28 pretty old for those times she was
probably considered an old maid by that
spinster by that time
and then the two of them came here and
she set some several records for first
ladies she was the first first lady to
have come from poverty
she was the first first lady to have
ever worked for a living
she was the first first lady to have
ever worked after marriage and after
becoming a mother so she was maybe
pretty radical for that time she was
also
quite the political advisor for
fillmore she was very conversant on all
the issues and was very
helpful to him amanda lockett how about
any other questions now that you've
heard this about her
no
when you go back to your fifth grade how
many students are in your fifth grade
class by the way
um 18 and when does school end for you
this year
24th the 24th it's coming up soon what
will you tell the other students in the
class that you've learned
well i've learned that she was a lot
more than just a school
good teacher well thank you for telling
us about fillmore days you're going to
go watch this year
yes
thank you for telling us all about it
fillmore days are in moravian new york a
festival in moravia
one of the places associated with
millard fillmore and the annual bathtub
race to uh celebrate a myth associated
with millard fillmore amanda lockett
thank you we'll hang up the phone now
but thank you for being with us and
adding to our discussion this morning
thank you
i'll film our days this year is august
7th we're getting back to the bathtub
the best source for any improvements at
all in the white house is the curator of
the white house
and because any improvements are done
through congress
and in 1974 which was the beginning of
our bathtub races
i have a letter from the curator
and he said you couldn't prove or
disprove that
because right following film wars
appears franklin pierce and improvements
were made in the white house including
the bathroom and that but nothing was
specified
and when you look at some of your early
presentation and let's say martin van
buren when water is pumped from the
lower
floor
by
upstairs to a bathtub and so on i mean a
lot of this was not far-fetched
uh
buchanan and wheatland when he was at
that home near lancaster
he said one reason why he had a bathtub
which was zinc lined in mahogany
was because of the bathtub is in the
white house so it's pretty close to that
whole period getting into the period but
i don't know why we get so excited about
that as an accomplishment of fillmore
uh rather than so many other things you
know let's take a telephone call from
washington dc next uh good morning i
want to tell you how much i'm enjoying
the show
this is al selzenberg i've been on the
show and very much enjoy what you're
doing for the president
i should say also if we ever run for
office i'm going to ask those young
children a single campaign jingle for me
i want to get to the relationship
between millard fillmore and abraham
lincoln they were both wigs
i came across a lincoln letter in 1856
where he was saying that he of course is
carrying the
the newly republican party banner for
his state but he couldn't persuade mrs
lincoln to get her friends to move away
from fillmore which made me think there
may have been some kind of a
relationship of when they were both
younger politicians
uh one last thing and this is not a
reflection on the guests you have on
today but it just seems that whenever
the race question has come up in the
entire series
of the president's before lincoln
the guest of the historian has very
often tried to
rationalize or explain if not defend the
president in question by citing mr
lincoln's notion about slavery being
constitutional
lincoln did call it an evil i'm not
aware that any president before him with
the exception of john quincy adam did
that uh and he pushed very very hard
where he could
uh there were alternatives mr fillmore's
leadership even in the state of new york
you had it mr stewart you've had it in
some others and lastly a previous caller
asked what books are out that talk about
the period
the best i know is henry mayer's all on
fire which is not only a biography of
william henry garrison william garrison
but a fantastic study of the fugitive
slave issue
from all sides he makes the case very
very clear
would you give the name again please
okay the the book is called all on fire
it's by henry mayer m-a-y-e-r
uh it's a biography of william lloyd
garrison thank you it takes the story
from about 1800 all the way to the end
of the civil war thank you we're going
to focus on that period with our next
guest who will be with us in just a few
minutes anthony cohen let me ask you sir
just very briefly define the wigs for us
our caller
you still there
we've lost him so i'm going to ask mr
scary would you define who the whigs
were
what what did they what was their major
reason for being as a political party
well you know in some ways they
believed in
internal improvements and canals and
roads they were sort of like that was
under the american system under henry
clay
in a sense they were very progressive if
you want to think of it that way
and
some some of the things that they
later got into in a whole slavery
question
you know uh
probably brought about their demise
business business and property i think
were their main emphasis
but they died and the wigs died in 52 at
the death of henry clay and well and
daniel webster it's pretty much the end
of it
again 52 i feel that this
fillmore really deserved to be
renominated
and if i think if he had would have won
bellevue washington good morning
hi
one of the biggest mistakes an american
can make is to not
study american history because they are
hung up on this whole slavery issue
and
the best way to keep it in proper
perspective
is to read denise de souza's book titled
the end of racism
especially chapter 3 where he asked the
question was slavery a racist
institution and he gives examples there
about how free black males owned other
black slaves
and
perhaps
your author there may want to talk about
that a little bit
and that's all i have to say goodbye
well you take this whole slavery issue
you know it's it uh
i don't know just just seems to me that
we just keep going over and over again
in november uh well twice in 1850
there was uh conventions in nashville
tennessee
and it was a threat of succession
the one that was most vocal was south
carolina the whole thing about it was
fillmore is no slave owner among all his
early presidents we had he was no slave
owner
of course adams weren't either but
and he was and he said this man said
there was no evil nobody ever said about
he he called it an evil
an evil that had to be tolerated
unfortunately
and so on
and uh the whole matter here was he was
for preservation of the union
one reason he didn't go to the
republican party like steward and others
he believed that the republican party uh
believed in sectionalism and so on and
so forth
and uh
unfortunately he got with the american
party
but he predicted the civil war if things
were went along the way
and since it was the framework of his
entire presidency and the country
getting closer and closer to falling
apart over this issue not a surprise
that we would spend a much of our time
talking about it in this period of
american history
we're going to meet another one of your
students in just a second
explain to our audience about the young
yorkers
the young yorkers is a history club we
focus mostly on new york state or local
history
and each year i try to take a different
emphasis with it this year it's been a
year-long emphasis on the underground
railroad and i've tried to teach the
children how to be historians they
started by interviewing their elders
they chose grandparents or elderly
neighbors to interview
and the first chapter of our book is the
result of those interviews and then they
we learned as much as we could about the
underground railroad through reading a
number of books for children we use the
internet for research i took uh several
of them including larry who's about to
ask a question up to the buffalo and
erie county historical society to do
research
we found there are several documents
that we purchased for use in our book
and it was very exciting to the children
i think they're real turned on to the
old process of history now
the young yorkers is an organization
that's statewide it's sponsored by the
new york state historical association in
cooperstown
and i really encourage people to get
involved because it can be
very motivating for the children the
young man who is about to be on your
screen is larry sievert who is part of
the young yorkers history club a student
at eggert elementary school
and larry sievert what do you like about
history
um i just
like to know what happened in the past
and
i guess
just what happened is your family
encouraging your exploration of history
uh yes are you are you teaching them
things or is your family already
interested in history um
my dad is
somehow well i'm i am teaching him a
little sort of
what can you tell
us about the period of time you spent
your last year studying on what's an
important fact to know about the
underground railroad and the fugitive
slave act um that it was not a
underground railroad some kids and
adults think that it was
a railroad
but it actually wasn't it was
a group of people some quakers
and some other people who would actually
have
they would
send signs and signals to people
saying you know that um they can go up
through
and go to their house and then stop and
then
get to the north
so no train cars on this railroad it was
in fact a pathway
to the north well i should tell our
audience where you are you are on the
lawn outside the millard fillmore home
here and it's just off main street in
east aurora new york and as you can see
the garden's in full bloom right now and
as you stand there let me ask you about
a question you might have for our guests
about millard fillmore um i was
wondering was he a good or a bad student
in school
why don't we ask your teacher rachel
francis was he a good or bad student
well he was he was not able to go very
often as we said he was a farm boy so he
would go in the winter for about three
months when there was someone who would
teach school
um
later on he went to this academy where
he ran into abigail and
he was a passionate learner there
he had a job as a wool carter
where he set himself up with a
dictionary in the middle of two spools
he had to change he would change the
spool
read a definition of a word and then
change another spool so i'm not sure he
was such a great employee if he was
doing that but he sure was passionate
about learning and then later on he was
connected with a quaker
judge in moravia who
taught him law but this was how he
taught him law he handed him a book of
law and said thee will turn thy
attention to this
and miller didn't quite know how to how
to sit down with a great big law book
and learn it so he he told a group of
students late in his life that what he
did was
copy it word for word
and that was how he took in that's how
he studied law on his own with very
little help from judge wood
larry sievert any reaction
uh no you answered my question very good
thank you thank you for asking it let's
take a telephone call from warsaw new
york
hi susan i'm just really enjoying your
presidential uh programs i really wish
they were available to grandmothers like
me so we could save them for our grand
or really pre-school young grandchildren
and i just love all of this information
however i am a lincoln file and
one i i have loads of lincoln books and
one of the threads that runs through
when they reversed
lincoln's
trip from springfield to washington with
with after he had been assassinated and
they brought the body back to all of the
major cities
buffalo was one of the ones that in
deference to miller fillmore apparently
uh because he was kind of like an arch
enemy of lincoln and really kind of
opposed lincoln all along
buffalo new york kind of
did not do as much as some of the other
cities did just strictly because of
millard fillmore i'll hang up and listen
to the comment on that robert scary you
are emphatically shaking your head no to
that i just agree on
on
lincoln
on his way to his inaugural he stopped
in buffalo
stayed overnight
with at fillmore's place they went to
church
and certainly they must have talked
about politics and that
and on the
train
going back to to uh springfield
uh they were stopping at various places
and fillmore was just in
in the head of a group of citizens
honorary citizens
to do this
and
hear comments about them were disliking
then lincoln and that and noah and so on
now during the civil wars parts or
things were happening in the civil war
where
he didn't maybe agree sometimes on the
military
fulfillment and things like that
and
supported
i think with general mcclellan
when he ran for the presidency
along the way but i disagree that he
disliked lincoln and so on he went on a
he went on a trip in the mississippi in
the west
in
1854 it was put
up by a
railroad magnet
and on the way back from that they went
on the mississippi
river up to saint paul and that whole
area of minnesota which was a territory
then and on the way back he stopped in
springfield
uh met
with lincoln
lincoln dunn was just a congressman and
that and so on i was just reading about
the uh the
the train the uh
that bore lincoln back after his
assassination and it stopped in buffalo
and it was
my understanding in the book that i read
that uh buffalo was working hard to
make up for lincoln's first visit
through buffalo someone evidently had
taken a saw to a platform on which
lincoln was
speaking and the city of buffalo was
embarrassed over this incident and they
were working very hard
in this in the funeral trains visit to
make up for that embarrassment so i
don't understand the the caller's
perception at all
we will be back with these guests in a
few minutes before we say goodbye to
them i want to tell you as you can see
there's something of a theme of
classrooms and young people with our
millard fillmore program this morning
we're hoping that teachers will find our
american president's series and
especially during the summer months when
more teachers are home and have a chance
to
flip around the dials we have a full
range of c-span in the classroom
materials so that you can teach about
american presidents and they are
available free of charge if you are a
teacher you can see there are two ways
to get the information one is on the
internet at cspan make sure you have
that hyphenate.org
classroom or you can telephone 202
626-4858
we are going to show you during our
break here some of the many
points in millard fillmore's long public
career and we'll be back in a couple of
minutes to talk with anthony cohen about
the whole history of slavery in america
during the 1850s leading up to the years
of the civil war
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to our continuing
conversation about the life and times of
our 13th united states president millard
fillmore we are live today from millard
fillmore's home which is established as
a tour site and museum in east aurora
new york about 30 miles
outside of buffalo and open for your
visits during these summer months if
you're interested in learning more about
the history of the
1820s through 30s which is when this
house was built and when he lived in it
and also more about the presidential
administration of fillmore which
happened 1850 to 18-53 we are in the
living room of this house and it's very
much a house of the period low ceilings
and small rooms and joining me on the
set is anthony cohen a historian and
we're going to plunge right into a
period of time that he knows well from
his research that's the 1850s and what's
happening in this country over the whole
issue of slavery set the stage for us
please
well i think
america during the 1850s uh was a powder
keg
just waiting to explode and
everybody knew it would
the main issue which
was
prevalent at the time led up
to the civil war was the issue of
slavery
america was expanding at the time
westward
and
[Music]
fulfilling its uh i guess a goal of
manifest destiny
to reach from c to c
and
there was
i think many roadblocks
for both the north and the south
to achieving that goal and how it would
be done
slavery
to many people
was looked at as an evil
to many people looked at as uh a
necessary evil
and to others as a blessing
and
that's where the uh the
battle began so to speak in 1850 millard
fillmore whom we're discussing today
signed into law the compromise of 1850
five provisions one of which was the
fugitive slave act what was it and what
did it do to the country
well
the fugitive slave act
which became the fugitive slave law
was actually a strengthening
of
the fugitive slave law of
1793 as early as 1787
with the northwest ordinance
which established that the territories
north of the ohio river
would become free territories
from that point on
the
issue of
fugitives from justice
and fugitives from labor
going from
a slave territory into a free territory
kind of
took the floor
it made it a federal crime to harbor or
assist a slave who was escaping is that
correct it made it a federal crime
it did not necessarily make it a state
crime
and as early as 1793 many of the
northern states
had yet to adopt laws
which would govern how they would demand
fugitives of any type
back to the south
that law
allowed for slave holders to actually go
into northern states
and reclaim their property
between
the early 1800s
and
1830 many of the northern states
were just abolishing slavery themselves
and so as acts of
gradual emancipation
were appearing in different states so
were laws that were
enacted to govern how free blacks
and slave holding people either resident
in those states or traveling through
those states
would be dealt with
we welcome your telephone calls if you'd
like to talk about millard fillmore
specifically you are most welcome to do
that if you'd like to talk about the
history of this period and about this
fugitive slave act and the compromise of
1850 and join in the conversation you
are most welcome to do that as well here
are the phone numbers 202-624-1111
for the eastern half of the united
states 202-624-1115
for those of you living in the mountain
and pacific time zones now anthony cohen
did some uh some experiential learning
about the underground railroad which
really got into high gear during this
period we're going to take a couple
calls and then learn about your trip and
what you learned los angeles good
morning
good morning i resent the fact that
many of your guests and callers are
attempting to
rationalize
the future this slave act and
particularly fillmore
and they have suggested many people have
suggested over and over again that it
was a necessary evil for example and
that they were attempting to keep the
union together i think this is quite
tragic
i mean when we speak of the situation in
germany for example with uh with the
holocaust i suppose a lot of people
could say that that was a necessary evil
but if we say that it's going to really
inflame a lot of people of the jewish
faith and some i think we should be
careful when we talk about this issue
now um
feel more there's no escaping
the fact that
this man defined slavery uh he made it
illegal for these poor people to escape
and so there was clearly nowhere to turn
under his administration but yet we are
praising him we have monuments to him
and i just think that it's a very tragic
situation and then i see finally i see a
lot of young children who are beginning
to learn about this man
and they're not learning so much
about his history
of crimes against humanity but they're
learning a lot of things that that are
quite pleasant and i think that we're
starting all over again when i see these
children
when you ask them tell me something
about fillmore they're not saying well
it's unfortunate that he was um a
slaveholder they're thinking of other
pleasantries so
i think actually the actually caller the
student who just
spoke talked about the underground
railroad so give us some credit for
actually mixing this in into the
discussion as well i will give that the
student credit you're correct the
student did indeed mention the
underground railroad
and
you know so i thought that but i again
i've seen a lot of the children i've
watched this series and it appears that
a lot of the children
know very little about slavery and
they're they're sort of being
desensitized and so i would suggest the
c-span
also have a show where they allow black
americans to discuss the legacy of
slavery with respect to these presidents
and it would be fair because we don't
have an opportunity here all we can do
is call in
okay thanks
well i don't know why you're frustrated
because you're calling in and
participating and helping all of us
learn in a program that's about all of
american history and that's really what
we're trying to do is have all of us
learn about the history of our country
so thank you for expressing your point
of view and anthony cohen take it away
yes um uh as a black american i can
relate to uh
much of the sentiment that the uh
caller express
i think there is um
a
a kind of sense in our country today
that to look back on the past
and
try and make any sense of it
is a dangerous thing to do
dangerous because
the
way we live in our culture today
our politics you know our social
structure
our
community
uh values are different from people uh
of the past and that somehow
if
we take too careful a look
i believe that we might see some of
ourselves
in those people
i agree with the caller that uh i think
so
often and for so long there have been
apologists
for slavery
many people
would express to me when i was growing
up
in the 60s and 70s that
you know slavery
wasn't acceptable at that time but it
was back in the
the times before lincoln and the reason
being was those were different people
and they had different thoughts
there was great opposition in this
country to slavery from its inception
uh states
today that we would
most readily
connect with the image of slavery such
as south carolina
and georgia in the very early years of
their developments as colonies
debated and questioned whether slavery
would be the direction
that they would go
in the mid-1700s
georgia nearly
prohibited slavery within its borders
but during the time of the the
revolution through the beginning of the
19th century
there were
great
changes in the country
economic population changes
and
through various
reasons
slavery
not only was accepted but began to
thrive
i think when we look back at
somebody
like millard fillmore and the period he
was in we have to realize that no single
person was responsible for the fugitive
slave law
but
that the national legislature the
congress of united states was the one
that passed uh and uh
various laws uh you know for nearly uh
70 years
which
allowed slavery to persist
so i think we need to start by looking
at it over a continuum and not
necessarily picking out uh the
individual uh uh elements for uh for uh
for blame cleveland you're next for
anthony cohen good morning yes good
morning
um i i just love the president's series
i think that it's really good
um and educational i i do agree with the
previous caller
uh in respect that um
most of the guests that do
appear and the many of the calls
are regarding uh or have a rejoicing
type of attitude
about the suffering of a race of people
and
regarding the the different slave type
of
industries
there were field workers and there were
breeders
and there were whites
that profited
from human cargo
during the 1850s there were reports
which documented estimates showing that
the products from slaves amounted to
over
136 million dollars
and that
cotton alone
amounted to 98 000
and this is just the estimates from one
year
um
through much and many long debates it
seems as if the founding fathers came to
the conclusion that they themselves
had become accustomed to the status quo
they grappled and they wrestle with
themselves and they realize they own
true feelings that living with negroes
as free people in america was definitely
something hard to phantom and this was
the first time that they had probably
realized that the institution called
slavery had become a way of life which
only benefited them and the years of
dehumanization and the abusive treatment
of negroes in america have never been
brought to the forefront and questioned
so my question in essence
is
was it deliberate
that no reparations were offered
and if we know
that congress the same body of people
even though they're the same
white people i mean it's sad to look at
this and now to find that people are
trying to justify
reasons why negroes or african americans
should not receive reparations even in
1999.
thank you cleveland let's let's get a
response from anthony cohen yeah i think
that's a great question um
i think we first have to uh say that
the
movement to abolish slavery
uh
began as soon as slavery began to
entrench itself in this country
i believe in
1745
massachusetts was the first state
to pass laws trying to prohibit the
importation of african slaves
and even called for uh death penalties
for um piracy
and uh people who who did that illegally
each generation
each
a new wave of lawmakers
either
push the move towards abolition forward
or back
fortunately because of how the north
developed industrially
slavery was not uh you know a necessary
facet of that
so it died out but it didn't just simply
die out it had to um it had to be
extinguished
by the people in those
regions
and what i think we do is when
we look at slavery we think okay you
know lincoln you know
uh you know drafted the emancipation
proclamation and it freed slaves which
of course it didn't
and the civil war was fought and then
slavery ended
uh yes uh slated slavery as codified by
the laws of our country ended but the
conditions of deprivation
did not
end at that time and we have still
been trying to as african-american
people
move forward even today
i think
when people talk about reparations
there are a few things that need to be
taken into consideration
reparations uh i think would have been
very
appropriate
for
the slaves
who
gained their freedom
after the end of the war um slaves in
our country
[Music]
built roads uh they cleared uh vast
amounts of forest converting them into
fertile lands they
built our cities and our transportation
systems
they
raised their families
the families of
presidents and
all of our national leaders
and they did this
at least in terms of uh of the national
forces that
that existed without any compensation
at the same time i think as people who
tried to put the past the slavery past
behind them who
worked
diligently to see that their following
generations would have more than they
could have at that time i find it
difficult personally uh you know some
five generations uh away from slavery
that people today would believe that
they could claim reparations on behalf
of their ancestors i believe the true
reparation from for slavery is number
one education the very thing they were
denied and that the second reparation
would be a national
museum to
honor the history of african american
people fullerton california you're on
the air as our discussion continues
about millard fillmore's presidency
good morning good morning thank you very
much for the program
nobody's touched on the
life of millard fillmore after the
presidency
especially during the civil war his
public life
uh any administrative jobs or anything
he's held and thank you and i'll hang up
and listen thank you very much we've we
touched on it briefly because he made an
extensive trip to europe following the
death of his first wife but how about if
we save a little more detail of that for
our final segment of the show when we'll
have our other two guests back thank you
for the call monroe new york go ahead
hi uh
i'm i'm calling to concur with uh two
earlier callers from the west coast uh
la and san diego
uh
we've seen you know his cute house up in
upstate new york and we've uh heard some
you know like fifth graders talk about
bathtub races and you know
all things but i like to discuss his
uh tenure as the head
or the figurehead
of the you know the end period of the no
nothing party
which was a little bit was discussed in
a little bit detail before why mr scary
i think his name was
but he kind of deflected the
anti-catholic
and anti-immigrant
uh standing of that party which
which i just could not understand i
couldn't fathom that party was founded
as a party
to combat
like irish immigrants and german
immigrants
and i can't understand like i mean even
though mayhem have expressed specific
anti-catholics
anti-catholic opinion by himself
his mirror leading that party gives
credence to it or gave credence to it
and helped it elect governors i think in
massachusetts and like
delaware and
i don't know i just think that is a
a huge mistake he made a totally
tarnished much of his career
now my specific question actually deals
with the uh
futures of slave act i want to i was
just saying it was before it was not uh
the present guest mr cohen but uh mr
scary he said it was you kind of likened
it to like a noble act
i was i always believed that as a
big noble act
one where it was just delaying the
inevitable one that
just
complicated things more
it was like a third way type movement
and it didn't really solve anything and
it just delayed conflict until the end
so i'd like to hear mr cohen's apartment
on the actual nature of the situation
act
was it was it a noble or ignoble act
well i believe the fugitive slave law
was an ignoble act um
but i also look at it as a desperate act
there was a feeling
among
southerners and
now that i've said that i want to
specifically say slave holding
southerners
we generally talk in terms of the north
and the south but
it was slaveholders
who occupied the
local state and national
legislatures they made all the southern
laws governing
slavery
and they held all the wealth in the
south so they should be held responsible
and not the southern people
at large
um
but i think uh
by the time that the 1850 law
was put into effect
you know the die had been cast in a
sense
the law was created
from a feeling by the part of slave
holders that the north wasn't honoring
its obligations
to return fugitive slaves
there was also another
feeling
that
that
slaves escaping
did not
seek out freedom in the north
on their own
that
the underground railroad
that the secret lines of of egress from
the south to the north were all part
of a uh
a deeply laid
and uh very efficient abolitionist
scheme to steal slaves
i think the greatest
thing that gets lost in the period is
in understanding that period is first
that the
abolitionists of the north in many cases
were southerners
it was the late 1700s
when the when many of the southern
quaker communities started freeing their
slaves
it was the early 1800s when many
southern legislatures started
passing laws prohibiting any free
discussion
on abolition or anything that would
question slave holding many of those
people went north
into free territories such as
ohio and
illinois
places where they could
settle
where they could improve the lands
uh in an environment that in an
environment which did not tolerate slave
holding
at the same time
as they left
many slaves followed and
you know after a few decades
it was evident that even though they had
removed themselves from slavery
that slavery was coming to their
doorstep
so
the 1850 law was really an attempt
to get northerners to comply
with
the federal laws that they were not
complying with and not only were they
not complying with them but in many
cases they would try to stymie them
masters going north trying to reclaim
property
were
often
served with the writs of habeas corpus
bringing them and
their
slaves before
judges
in the north different from the south
a slave could testify on his
own behalf
in many of these courts
in many cases get a jury trial
and
prove his freedom whether he was
by federal law free person or not
and uh that was the goal of the fugitive
slave law
at the same time
um there was
little feeling that it would really do
good
and as we saw in the 1850s it was
confronted many times we have a call
next from tuolumne california good
morning
yes ma'am
i was wondering if your guests speaker
there could
comment a little bit on the ties
between the underground railroad and the
west african country of liberia
if i recall
there was a group of northern
abolitionists
purchased
liberia for the reparation act actually
the repatriation of the
blacks
and this was pretty well an older
encyclopedia this is pretty well spelled
out
there was clearly
clearly purchased for that
repatriation yet less than 10 percent
of the current population of liberia
are descendants of the old slaves thank
you for your call well
your question actually gives rise to us
very briefly explain what the
underground railroad was and what
happened to people who participated in
after the fugitive slave act
well the underground railroad can be
defined as an organized system of escape
it was a series of
transportation routes
natural
routes of escape rivers valleys
mountain ranges fields and thickets
slaves hid out in swamps
all in a line running
generally to the north
once they reached a free state
they were taken into communities by
benevolent people such as free blacks
and quakers who would supply them with
food and clothing and shelter and
direction further north
the underground railroad went south into
mexico
slaves escaped into the western
territories those in the gulf uh went to
uh haiti and uh uh the the british
colonies
and um some slaves even back to africa
now mr cohen you are you've been
researching this for a number of years
and in fact have a book that will be
published next year by hyperion about
your experiential
learning going on some of the roots we
have some videotape uh that we're going
to show the audience and would you tell
us about your journey and why it was
important to actually retrace the route
yes
back in
the spring of 1996
i followed a route of the underground
railroad that i documented from sandy
springs maryland to amherst burgot
ontario
and
my goal at first was to take the secret
system
for which
not
a lot of documentation seems to exist
and to find documentation
and as i was able to
look at old diaries and letters and
manuscript collections and
even interview people
today who are in their 90s who as
children had met the former
abolitionists in runaways who were then
in their 90s and got direct oral history
i was able to re-piece
these routes and then i decided to walk
the routes to see what i would find
along the way how many miles have you
covered
well on the first walk i think it was
about 350 miles
by foot i went by foot boat and rail
and i think the total on that journey
was about 800 miles to reach
niagara falls
most
fugitives
sought out the transportation systems
boats
wagons and other conveyances
trains sometimes they follow the tracks
sometimes they stowed away
on trains sometimes
road on the top of
of trains even
to reach the north
because you wanted to get to your
destination as quickly as possible
you you utilize that transportation
i used only the methods that were
available to fugitive slaves as i went
from place to place there's another one
of our students from the edgard road
school who has a question for you his
name is cullen ware he joins us now live
from hillard fillmore's home in east
aurora with a question about the
underground railroad colin good morning
good morning
what's your question
uh my question is um
what is the actual what are the odds of
a
a runaway slave
getting to
canada or the north
thank you very much what were the odds
the odds were good uh depending on which
time period they were traveling
in the
mid to late 1700s
slaves sometimes did go to what we now
call free states even though those
states had slavery
as slavery started to be abolished and
those lines of escape were formed
it was very easy to reach
a free state slaves mainly
traveled at night and slept by day so
that they could use public roads without
being seen
when they got to free states
they established communities
settled in previously existing ones and
live normal lives it was really the
fugitive slave law of 1850
which turned the north into a hunting
ground
for runaways that
provoked many to go to canada
and by that time
in opposition to the fugitive slave law
more northerners and northern
communities
organized
it wasn't highly efficient organization
but it was a loose networking of people
and places who's provided different
modes of transportation and different
assistance during our next telephone
call we'll actually show you uh we will
show you some actual video rather of a
period of this trip where anthony cohen
had himself boxed in a box similar to
one used by a fugitive slave and put on
a railroad car to travel
to really get the feel for some of the
conditions about some of the escaping
slaves we'll show you that and we're
going to listen to flagler florida good
morning caller good morning
now being a historian is a great thing i
love history so much but in history
there have been evil men and there's
been evil deeds done i wish you guys
would leave it alone
you got uh
wayne mcbuckley now trying to say
mccarthy was misunderstood
he was really a nice guy and he was
right you got another guy i've seen on
book notes you write the book that j.p
morgan was a pussycat a real nice guy i
don't see anybody trying to apologize
for kane for killing abel
uh
stop apology apologizing in england i
understand they don't even teach history
because their history is so atrocious
they're trying to blame the irish
landlords because talleyrand starves six
million old
irishmen and children and somebody comes
along and they try to change it leave it
alone or you can serve this guy do this
fella history is history evil deeds have
been done and don't try to apologize for
him thank you thanks very much would you
count millard fillmore as one of the
evil men of american history
um evil i think is is relative to
where you are as an individual and again
that's not an apologist statement um i
look at some of the most respected
people of our day and age and think
their evil incarnate
but
i don't put them in public office
at the same time
i think
slavery without question was evil
and
i think it can go unquestioned or
without question because we all still
suffer from
the remnants of slavery today and it has
been abolished for over 130
some odd years so i think that's
evidence enough of the evil which the
caller is speaking of
at the same time
i'm 35 and growing up
there was very little discussion uh in
any class
room that i ever sat in of slavery a
matter of fact
when i was in eighth grade
our coverage of the civil war lasted one
class period
and
and so
i think
i think today at least we have the
ability
to learn more and discuss more and have
more tools for
discussing difficult periods of our time
phil moore i think
if i can use a strong word
was a minion
of the
politics of the time
and that in no way
makes him
any more
responsible or any less responsible
for
what happened
in terms of the passage of the fugitive
slave law and its effects
the great thing about the fugitive slave
law was it galvanized people who
could have taken a kind of a moderate
position and had taken a moderate
position on slavery and put them in a
situation where they had to make choices
the fugitive slave law successfully
allowed southerners to come into north
into the north
to
arrest
and
carry back slaves without due process
it gave them a federal force to do this
any federal
commissioner
past or present
could be deputized as a marshal of the
federal government they had the powers
to
seize slaves
without warrant
they
could
make summary judgments
without this lady having the benefit of
a
trial by jury
and
the people of the north
as i said galvanized many
rescues
were uh enacted
and um it brought the attention of
fugitive slaves who a decade previously
were quietly uh carried back to the
south and their stories never known and
in an irony it sounds as though a region
of the country which was really pushing
the idea of individual states rights
turned to the federal government to
enforce an institution that it found
favorable absolutely
columbia south carolina good morning
good morning uh
you talked about appreciation i'm really
happy to hear you talk about this
subject and and the whole subject of
slavery because
it's obviously a history that is not
taught to this day in school and it's
not taught to very young people
and it's very important that they young
people get this full history so that
they can strengthen them so they're able
to deal with the lies
and omissions
of history
today
i'm an
illustrator and i illustrated a book
called the middle passage
the
that painful trip just told through
pictures i wanted young people
to see
uh and feel this history and one of the
things that i found out that when they
see it
and feel it
many of them especially the white
children
so they did not know this history
and they did not know how bad it was
one of the reasons why you find people
able to apologize for this is because
the history is not shown
and people are not uh
cannot put themselves into the
uh situation
uh put their self into the shoes of
africans
who went through slavery everybody knows
that no one wants to be a slave
uh so artists and historians have to
write this material and write it for
very young people i think it was tony
morrison who said the consequences of
slavery
only artists can deal with and it's our
job that is to make you feel it
thanks for your call from columbus i
appreciate it now we have a young person
one of the students with us this morning
and you saw from our picture outside we
have a number of students here and many
people watching our production
next you'll meet carolyn randall who has
also a question on the underground
railroad carolyn go ahead
my question is what uh
what other churches were involved with
the underground railroad besides the
quakers carolyn before you go can you
tell us and our audience listening
anything you learned about the
underground railroad i learned about
harriet tubman and how many trips she
made who was harriet tubman um a very
famous
undergrad a very famous black woman that
kept going back to the south the south
and
north going down
to save the slaves and take them back to
the north and what grade are you in in
the edgard road elementary school
thanks for your question and the
question is anthony cohen how many
churches were involved with the
underground railroad uh well quite a few
the unitarians
were involved
congregationalists were involved
some
sections of
methodists
were involved
many of the german people
moravians seven day baptists were
involved
it's estimated that there were by 1860
up to 6 million
people in this nation who belonged to
churches which had abolished slave
holding uh within its ranks
and can you tell me a little bit more
about
whether or not the churches formally
encouraged that
some did
for instance
the quakers took the lead
in the just after the revolutionary war
first to
request amongst their members that they
grant a policy of gradual emancipation
and by the early 1800s they had outright
abolished slavery
we have as you can see as you're
watching invited our two guests who are
with us for the first part of our
program back to join us for our final 25
minutes rachel francis who is a teacher
in this part of
new york state she teaches uh students
in third grade and also has a fifth and
sixth grade history club fourth and
fifth fourth and fifth thank you uh
called the young yorkers who are
learning about the history of this time
and specifically did a project on the
underground railroad this year and
robert scary who is a long time now
retired history teacher from moravian
new york who is very interested in the
life and times of millard fillmore and
has a thousand page manuscript which
will be published on millard fillmore's
life our three guests will spend our
final 25 minutes with us and we had a
question while you were gone about what
happened to miller fillmore after he
left the presidency was he continuing to
be involved in politics what was his
life like
well he he was a
a great citizen in buffalo of taking
uh getting involved in many of the
activities and buffalo is the first
president of the
founder of the buffalo historical
society
he was affiliated with the general
hospital in fact today there's a
hospital named after him in buffalo
he was very much involved at the spca
it was a second
organization in the nation for against
the cruelty of animals
most of it was civic
organizations
and he was in the forefront of all that
anybody who came to buffalo like andrew
johnson
um famous
individuals at that period
he would probably invariably be one of
the members of the welcome committee and
so on
and rachel francis what about his second
wife
his second wife was named caroline she
was a younger woman than he
she had lost her first husband so she
was a widow
and had no children of her own
i think the main attraction frankly that
millard felt for her was for her
money she was very um
wealthy from her first husband and uh he
also
found it difficult after he left the
presidency uh trying to figure out what
to do with himself he didn't think it
was right for an ex-president to go back
into the practice of law so it was
awkward for him this issue of money and
caroline
sort of saw that for him they had a
prenuptial agreement uh under which she
was keep she would keep all her money
but he would be paid i think it was ten
thousand dollars a year for the
management of her money
and uh it was he who had recommended to
congress that there be a pension for
retired presidents for the first time
and he had recommended as a fee for that
twelve thousand dollars a year so he he
made arrangements for himself a little
bit under that
but in fact was congress agreeable i
don't think that happened for quite a
while i'm not sure he didn't give any
pensions to i think even past the days
of harry truman to um
but he did presidents he spent most of
his days in in philanthropy he was the
leading citizen of buffalo i don't think
there's anyone who did more for buffalo
than millard fillmore in its founding
years and uh he spent most of his time
in reading and study
take a call from morrison missouri
hello you're on the air welcome oh i'm
so happy to be on
uh this is a little outside but then
again i want to tell mr cohen i am uh
vicksbud
and uh i have a
grand a grandfather who was half black
at least and i have a
grandmother who was half cherokee indian
and we were proud of it and raised to be
proud of it i'm now 76
my parents always
you know told us about our history
we had the most lovely grandparents
and my grandfather
was going um
evidently born as a result of the escape
that went up the rivers in indiana
and uh to a white girl evidently and
was taken in and raised and he became
one of the outstanding
doctors in indiana
and your point
your point for telling us your family
history is what what do you want us to
draw from
we hear from so many people who
are hurt
and look back with pain and i look back
sort of in glory i got you know i've had
a chance to be part of a wonderful
family
and one that was um upfront about
everything
and who did change with our 20th century
here and i'm just so proud
thank you for your call appreciate it
anthony cohen what's your reaction
yeah i think the the caller makes a a
very interesting point um
i i think americans approach slavery
from a place of shame and guilt
and uh i used to think that it was
black people approach it from a place of
shame and anger white people from a
place of shame and guilt
but
i think we're all shamed by slavery
and
i found among both races
the urge to um
to kind of vary any history that doesn't
speak to who and what they are today
i look
at history our history as an american
people as a measure of how far we've
come
and
uh
you can debate the fugitive slave law
and was it right for somebody to pass it
which i don't believe it was and was
this person really forward or against it
but we don't debate the fact that there
was a need for a fugitive slave law
that it wasn't simply
a north-south dichotomy
slaves escaping were southern people
but southern people without rights
and they were helped out of the south by
poor whites free blacks the sons and
daughters of slaveholders who opposed
their parents positions
and they were helped in the north by
benevolent people and so i think for
every issue you have to look at both
faces you know both sides of the coin
edmond oklahoma
that lady who talked and and i agree
slavery is terrible and
there should have been reparations at
the time
but she said millard fillmore was a
slave owner but he was not a slave owner
and i think that should be
set right
and i had one set of grandparents who
lived in kentucky at the time of the
civil war great grandparents
and i'm so proud of my great grandfather
because he
they were against slavery
but
all of the
the free black men in
hosville kentucky could come to him
and have him check the money that they
had received for their work
and he taught them how to to
about change and about money and he lost
several friends because he told them
those friends that they were not giving
their
workers as much as they should
he
he helped him all he could and then my
grandmother sent several
black
students through the university she she
was a teacher and she
it
shared what she had with them
there are a lot of people like that and
i just education is
the one the thing by which we can
help everybody the most thanks edmond
oklahoma
i think the underground railroad project
that we did was very valuable in the
values that it taught the children in
compassion for people uh that have
difficult situations in uh cooperation
of all the different races the blacks
and whites and the native americans who
work together to help the underground
railroad work and the courage that it
took to stand up and figure out what was
the right thing to do maybe not the
legal thing to do but the right thing to
do i think these are all very valuable
lessons for children to receive so i
think the underground railroad
should receive an elevated position in
our educational system because of these
values one of your students mentioned
harriet tubman another person very
active during this period of time and in
this part of the country sojourner truth
who was she
so gerner truth was a
new york slave
from new pulse
new york
i believe
that she was born in the late 1780s or
early 1790s
and
she is the prime example
of what we miss
in our lessons on slavery
she was a slave of a dutch
dutch slave master
and
she gained her freedom through
new york's emancipation uh in 1827-28
and
unfairly and against the laws of the
state i believe two of her children i
may be wrong in the number but two of
her children
had been sold before the passage of that
law
and having been born after the year 1799
they were entitled to their freedom
and she brought suit against the state
of new york and won and the state had to
retrieve her children from i believe it
was alabama
and i think
that story
speaks directly to what we miss and
that's the fact that slaves were not
ignorant people
who
were simply brought over from africa and
put into the fields with a hoe in their
hand to work
these are people
who not only built their country but
agitated within the system of slavery
to improve not only their lives but the
lives of all people and i think that was
and and pardoned me for using this term
uh slavery's great gift to america
was uh this uh fiercely independent
people that we believe ourselves to be
were also people who had to learn the
lessons of humanity and slavery was that
great lesson
and we're still learning it today i
believe gross isle michigan good morning
to you yes good morning first of all let
me thank you for this excellent series
which is so informative
uh the reason that i'm calling in i i'm
interested in a global context during
the first half of the 19th century
i believe slavery was abolished in the
british empire in 1837
and the tsar of russia freed the serfs
in the 1850s
i'm trying to view this as a world
situation not strictly as an american
historical situation
how
did
the united states
fit into the
worldwide global
history of emancipation of slaves and
served
thanks very much robert scary do you
have some thoughts on that well
fillmore as i said before wasn't a slave
owner
new york abolished slavery in 1827.
he believed in graduate emancipation
there were some who believed in outright
emancipation and also compensation
emancipation
that a lot of the
slaveholders that say sure i've got
slaves worth so much you pay me for it
you know and i'll free him all this kind
of thing
um
from from a global standpoint
one of the things that bothers me and i
wonder if there's an answer from anthony
here
how does he account for the fact that
you take the 19th century
and
18th century
no white men except for the latter part
of 19th century would venture into the
interior of africa it's called the dark
continent
and how does he count for the fact that
if it wasn't for black chieftains
who would tribal warfare
took prisoner
their fellow blacks
hold them in custody until a slave
trader came along
and then they
traded this these people to them they're
black brothers
how do you count for that
i'd like to account for that in in two
ways um that was definitely uh the
history of uh of how the african trade
uh
evolved from i believe
1472 when the portuguese built the first
slave castle to process and and export
slaves uh uh from west africa uh to the
new world
um yes
africans uh
sold slaves to europeans of all
different uh stripes but you use the
term brother and the fact is that they
black brothers no they were not black
brothers tribal warfare uh africa was
full of myriad uh nations and
ethnicities and religions and uh you
know one tribe going to war with another
group were not necessarily going to war
with their brothers it would be like
saying you know that
catholics and protestants in northern
ireland were brothers and sisters
at the same time
africa has
started acknowledging its part in the
slave trade
no one
will
will
claim that africans in any way
enticed a slave
trading merchants over to their shores
but they gladly sold them to slaves when
when when
when they established themselves there
and now places
countries such as ghana are looking
at granting reparations to
black americans in the form of dual
citizenship
because of the slave trade
that caller's question and we've got
another one waiting so maybe we can it's
a big question but his question was
really what was happening around the
rest of the world with regard to this
can you uh do you have any knowledge of
it yes the period after the
revolutionary war was uh
really where uh worldwide emancipation
really got its foothold
the u.s congress
in 1807 uh debated and passed the law
which went into effect in 1808
abolishing
the african slave trade meaning you
could not legally bring slaves from
africa into america but of course by
that time the northern
states slave holding states of maryland
delaware virginia
were faltering in terms of agriculture
and their great numbers of slaves were
then shipped south and so there was a
domestic trade so when we think about
about slavery
uh you know by the time of the
underground railroad people who escaped
on the underground railroad were second
third and fourth generation american and
not african
britain took the lead but many people
contributed
support
from india from france
all sorts of parts of
europe
to
what was going on here in america
portland oregon you're on the air
yes good morning
i was a little bit
wondering why maybe you've had this
already because i haven't been up very
long and i didn't get the first part but
why didn't
mr fillmore not have a vice president
and who was his first wife rather than
carolyn mcintosh thank you very much why
did he not have a vice president
well they didn't replace them then
i'm not sure when that began but they
didn't replace them at that point so he
served without a vice president and what
was the second question whose first wife
was who his first wife was abigail
abigail a wonderful educated supportive
woman who was um
very much like hillary clinton as far as
being his advisor she was very well
informed and for that caller it is for
abigail that millard fillmore built this
house he lived they lived in it as a
young couple 1826 to 1830. here in the
town of east aurora new york and there
you can see a picture from on top the
c-span school bus that gives you a sense
of where this is very much a residential
street in this in this town a bit of a
bedroom community for buffalo lots of uh
families living around here and right on
the street with lots of folks regular
houses is the millard fillmore house
which is open for touring two dollars
for you to come by to east aurora and
tour it during the nice weather months
we have only about eight minutes left in
our discussion of millard fillmore let's
go to a call from hickory north carolina
good morning good morning uh first of
all i'd just like to commend c-span for
the
series on the president's i've watched
most of them and really enjoyed them
the lady who called from portland just
to
clarify answer her question the 25th
amendment was the one that allowed
for vice presidents to be replaced
like if someone ascended to the office
so every president who uh vice president
ascended
prior to that served without a vice
president until either the next election
or a new president came in because
there's no constitutional mechanism to
replace the vice president
and just so
right and so just to clarify that in
case we weren't so specific
that he was vice president to zachary
taylor who died in office after about
one year and he served miller fillmore
served out the last three years of
zachary taylor's term and was not
elected although he was interested in
receiving the nomination of his party
the wigs were falling apart at that time
i think if he had made it known that he
was interested in it it would have
happened and it probably would have
extended the life of the wig party um he
was being very modest and um
uh waiting to be asked waiting to be
asked and he kept himself out of the way
he was trying to do the honorable thing
which is really a definition of millard
fillmore he was always trying to do the
honorable thing sometimes to his own
detriment
anyway he was not asked and he he
probably could have won if he had been
the wig candidate then
well the weak convention was held in
baltimore all film had to do with just
go over and probably say i'm i'm really
interested and that would be it
i stayed in washington
and on the first ball they didn't have a
majority first bout he led
and uh you know i just feel that that
was a mistake and it was daniel daniel
webster that uh held votes
and then
he wouldn't shift to fill more philbert
showed some disinterest when he finally
decided that he'd be interested
by that time it's too late when phil
scott was in the lead i wanted to bring
out something that anything brought out
that this whole question of slavery and
you know so
emotional in the way we're involved in
it uh granted
you know that we
have made mistakes and
we just don't seem to
to be together on on some things but
he uh
he was crucified in a way he he was an
abolitionist in the south and he was a
pro-slavery person in the north and all
this all his life really from his youth
he he was against this issue the future
of slave law was the most hated law in
the united states up to prohibition
you know all those years
and uh
you know it's unfortunate i just and an
untuned you look at the constitutionist
and the preamble says in order to form a
more perfect union
we're not a perfect nation
maybe we'll never will be
but we have tried to work
towards some of the mistakes of the past
try to rectify them
and you know try to correct things maybe
we never will
but we're not a perfect nation but i'll
say this much i take this nation over
any other
and i think one of the important things
is
when we talk about history we often say
mistakes we made
and that is
tying us into a greater
stream of responsibility
i believe that history doesn't repeat
itself i believe you can't
learn
the lessons from the past i believe that
every generation
has to experience and make decisions on
its own you can reference the past and
so we have to allow our ancestors and
what they did
to be their responsibility
it's up for us to see
how we as a culture
have evolved from that point and what
we're going to do about it in the
present and in the future we have only
four minutes left and what we're going
to do is take our last two callers who
are on the line right now and then come
back to our group tacoma washington go
ahead
yes uh this is uh george i grew up
across from harriet tubman's home in
auburn new york
and as a child i learned a lot of
history
about harriet tubman
and i really appreciated the fact that i
had that ability to do that
one of the things that i remember
greatly was some of the
people that lived in the area there who
had
great grandparents and so forth that
knew mrs tubman personally and spoke
about
her as a person
and and what a wonderful person she was
and
how much she helped to
establish
a lot of the the blacks that were freed
from the south into the northern
territories
and also she had mentioned to me that
many times that there were many white
families
in the area
that helped to
bring these people
north
to help get them established along with
mrs tubman and
i remember my great grandfather
knew a woman who had
helped several black individuals from
the south get educations and learn about
uh dealing with money issues and things
like that so thanks
thank you i'm going to let you go our
time is really running out appreciate it
and we as you can see we visited harriet
tubman's home and had some photos i want
to leave some time for our guests to
answer martin martinsburg west virginia
you'll be our last caller
go ahead please hello there
i grew up in uh in east aurora and i
graduated from high school there
did you know about millard fillmore
pardon did you know about millard
fillmore when you were looking we knew
that his law offices about the location
where cadets clothing store was
but i think one of the things that
impressed us that impressed me most was
the fact that about a block east of
there
were at least one place that had been
part of the underground railroad that
was more fascinating than the fact that
millard fillmore had an office there
and one thing that i found out today was
kind of neat that he was the 13th
president
and that was my uh number on my jersey
and track and cross country
thank you for the call appreciate it
well to our guest for closing comments
you wanted to mention harriet tubman
once again yes this is uh i think what
every american should do and that is to
talk to people who have lived through
history
harriet tubman escaped from slavery in
1849 exactly 150 years ago and i met two
weeks ago a woman whose grandfather
um uh was a doctor and cared for the
elderly people at that home in auburn
and told the story that uh that the the
man hated black people and um how
harriet would keep coming up with uh you
know different illnesses for him to
treat until uh he was she was able to
win him over
so we're still connected to the past uh
with uh living people and we should
pursue that we have two minutes left i'm
going to ask each of our guests for
final comments things that people should
most remember about millard fillmore
well i think the legacy of film war was
to postpone the civil war for 10 years
in that time
the north grew in population skilled
labor
railroads merchant marine
so on
enabling to win the war eventually and
he opened
japan to trade
and he
made brigham young the first territorial
governor of utah
and they named the capital fillmore in
the county of millard
rachel francis
i think an important lesson is that he
came from nothing he came from a log
cabin and became the leader of the free
world and mostly because of his
passion for learning his passion for
education and his um desire to do the
right thing that was his lasting lesson
from his father
his father would say millard do the
right thing
and it i think as he made his choices
through his political career that we can
find now from 1999 so easy to criticize
i think he still was searching each time
to do the right thing for the country
we have some thank yous as we always do
as we end these programs because there's
a lot of work there are so many of us
from c-span involved here but also
thanks to marie schneider for allowing
us to bring our cameras inside the
millard fillmore hoshi's co-curator here
and to the students of the young yorkers
club
who asked many of the questions and
helped us with our song and our three
guests anthony cohen robert scary and
rachel francis all who have helped us
understand a little bit more about the
life and times of millard fillmore the
united states 13th president on he did
not
get re-elected or get elected rather in
the next election in 1852 that honor
went to franklin pierce and on this
coming monday we will be live from
concord new hampshire for new
hampshire's own franklin pierce to learn
more about the life of our 14th
president join us beginning monday at 9
00 a.m eastern time well we're going to
close with music as we began and rachel
francis tell us very briefly about our
musicians would you brought them along
today bob sword is the guitarist and
keith wooden is the fiddle and uh
they're famous easter musicians we're so
happy to have him here and we'll listen
to music from the 1850s as we say
goodbye to millard fillmore house in
east aurora new york
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
if you'd like more information on any of
the 41 american presidents covered in
our series check our website start at
cspan.org and click on the american
president's icon
that'll take you to our special web area
where you'll find archival documents
information on buying american
president's products and driving
directions to all the historical